now to reaction of that IG report from
the White House for president Trump is
taking the day off essentially from
public events celebrating his 72nd
birthday all that possibly being
overshadowed by a legal challenge coming
out of New York to the president's
Terrible Charitable Foundation
correspondent Kevin cork reports for us
tonight
certainly there are a lot of things in
this report that not only worry those of
us in the administration but should
worry a lot of Americans even as the
White House today offered its full
throated support for the Inspector
General's report it was a lawsuit from
New York State that really got the White
House's attention the current acting New
York AG has stated that battling the
White House is the most important job
she's ever done
that sounds outrageously biased and
certainly problematic in it New York
State Attorney General Barbara Underwood
accused the Trump Foundation of illegal
conduct including coordinating with the
Trump presidential campaign in 2016 the
suit aims to dissolve the Trump
foundation obtain restitution of nearly
three million dollars and includes
referral letters to both the IRS and FEC
the suit alleges the Trump foundation
illegally provided extensive support to
his 2016 presidential campaign with
Underwood calling the charity a little
more than a checkbook for payments from
mr. Trump or his businesses to
nonprofits regardless of their purpose
or legality investigators point to a
January 2016 email from former Trump
campaign manager Corey Lewandowski
asking for money for veterans charities
in Iowa just before the caucuses there
indeed the AG's office says at least
five $100,000 grants were made there
right before votes were cast in the
Hawkeye State but the president pushed
back on Twitter calling New York
Democrats sleazy saying they're suing a
foundation that took in eighteen point
eight million dollars and gave out to
charity more money than it took in
nineteen point two million I won't
settle this case the Trump foundation
added succinctly this is politics and
it's very worst the suit is just the
latest in a steady stream of legal
actions aimed at the president or his
associate from former national security
adviser
Mike Flynn and former Trump campaign
manager Paul Manafort to the suit
brought by former adult film performer
stormy Daniels and persistent
accusations that the president has
violated the Constitution's he monuments
clause bred three of the president's
children Don jr. Eric and Ivanka Trump
were also all named in that lawsuit by
the New York AG because each has served
as a board member of the Trump
Foundation